the reason why we go back to old habits
is because our goal is are to lofty
we're not achieving our goals fast
enough like I think think they meet
people like you know they're like
they're robots they're other life-forms
they're just different than me
know we build habits rituals and
disciplines that serve us one way to
think about habits is that they are the
solutions to the recurring problems that
you face in life want to be happy
build a life not just a business so
today let's live your best belief life
and learn how you can break your bad
habits let's kick it off with rule
number one get us strong enough why with
Ed my light left to my own devices right
if you just left me like what I'd like
to do I hate a man I have no problem
laying around I like sleep like I think
the thing they meet people like you know
they're like they're robots they're
other life-forms they're just different
than me know we build habits rituals and
disciplines that serve us okay now part
of those habits rituals and disciplines
have sort of turned me into a more
confident person there's no question
about that
so my standards are mandatory because
you get your standards right and so the
reason my standards are set home so high
is because I don't want to leave it up
to my own devices right my standard is
one more minute on the treadmill my
standard is one more person I can reach
that day one more phone call one more
something and so for me I raise them
every single year but the way I get to
do it as I link it to my reasons and so
goals are really empty to me I have a
thing on goal-setting but like my big
thing is that you show me someone with
compelling emotional gigantic reasons
I'll show you someone who's changing
their standards all day long so like
give you one quick version that you not
heard before one of the reasons I'm
relatively fit is not just peak State my
have an uncle in my family that died at
50 years old of a heart attacks my
godfather my dad's only brother I kind
of
resemble them and I look like I Milan so
on the way back from his funeral my
reticular activating on heart attacks on
the TV screen on the airplane I'm
listening to music is the Oprah Winfrey
Show she's going through a new heart
scan mmm I've unplugged my headphones
plug it into the airplane one the time
of this new scan at cedars-sinai that at
that time was new it could read the
plaques and your arteries the
calcifications without going you know
really invasively I scheduled it I went
in I had a world-class doctor who
understood reasons and levers instead of
just prescribing clues but when we coach
people you need to do this she needs you
this the doctors do it take just pill
take this
he understood leverage and reasons what
you do is you take the scan then you go
to lunch you come back I took the scan I
went to lunch I had a burrito I came
back and I'm in the LA when I walk in I
sit down the doctor comes up and he says
oh my I can't believe these arteries are
in that young body got my attention
we walk back in we sit down he could
still go you need Crestor eat clean get
out of here is know what an average
doctor does right no wired me with huge
reasons he goes let me ask you a
question I heard your wife's pregnant
you have I said I have a son and he says
do you want to be there when he
graduates from high school to be there
for that day I said yes sir yeah he goes
your wife's pregnant what do you have
and I said a daughter is where you get a
dad he goes she was six months pregnant
he goes do you um would you like to walk
her down the aisle on her wedding day or
are you okay that it's some other man I
went what the [ __ ] is on this scan right
like and he goes I want to be very clear
with you if you keep going down the road
you're going there'll be some other man
with your son at graduation high school
and a strangers walking your daughter
down the aisle that's not even born yet
on her wedding day
and I went boom and he goes but if you
do exactly what I tell you to do you'll
be there and so to this day brother
there are mornings when I wake up not
every morning I don't want to go to the
gym I go Bella's wedding Bella's wedding
Bella's wedding so my standards are high
because of my big old reasons other
dudes may miss the gym that day because
they're not gonna miss their daughter's
wedding if they don't go but I've
convinced myself I will get emotional
I've convinced myself on this my
daughter's wedding so I will get my ass
out of bed at 4 o'clock in the morning
and I will get to that gym because my
reasons are bigger so my standards are
higher so that's what I think causes us
to have great standards is huge
seasons rule number two enjoy the moment
with David Goggins the reason why we go
back to old habits is because our goals
are too lofty we're not achieving our
goals fast enough so what happens is you
know what man we're very impatient
nowadays for me it was good I have a
phone I was I was I was out of this
world by myself it was a race against
David Goggins
it wasn't race against God I would look
good for this person to that person it
was me I got to change myself so for me
if I lost five pounds in the week I got
a feeling I allowed myself to feel proud
of that I didn't look I got lose a
hundred and six pounds I'm like man I
went from 297 now I'm 292 in one week
man I'm killing it we don't we're not
proud of ourselves for the small
accomplishments what we need is we need
this monstrosity of the thing to happen
say I did it now there's a process that
you have to go through and patience is
the process and if we don't have
patience after a week I haven't lost 30
pounds when I'm done I'm over it so
that's why I found out with people man
they're not paced enough to realize and
to enjoy the moment not living it just
enjoy it
there's no finish line in life but enjoy
that moment Roger that man lost five let
me go ten next week so that's the whole
thing about it that's how people lose it
also if you want to learn how to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links are in the
description below you have to go build
self-confidence the reason people don't
put themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today and rule
number three find the alternative
solution with James clear the third
choice is the one that you just
mentioned which is you take the solution
that the bad habit is providing the way
that it's serving you and you find a new
behavior that delivers that same outcome
so one way to think about habits is that
they are the salut
chins to the recurring problems that you
face in life so you know in a sense if
you put your shoe on your shoe is untied
that's a problem that you need to figure
out right and so at some point the first
time maybe that requires some effort but
once you tie your shoes 100 or 500 times
you can pretty much automate that
solution and do it on autopilot the same
is true for pretty much every area of
life right like if you come home from
work and you're stressed and exhausted
that's a problem that you need to figure
out but there are a variety of solutions
that could solve it you could play video
games for an hour you could smoke a
cigarette you could go for a run for 20
minutes you could meditate for 10
minutes and any of those solutions
whatever one that you come into your
brain starts to fall into that like the
mom who's going to McDonald's which is
like I have a problem I need to feed my
kids it's 5:30 and McDonald's is now a
solution and you're like hey this was
easy I should just automate the solution
as much as I can and so the key is to
try to find a solution that delivers the
same outcome that solves the same
problem but is also about as convenient
as the previous one otherwise it's
really hard cuz they ain't just you're
trying to opt for a less convenient
solution and the brain doesn't want to
do that it wants to automate and
conserve energy not spend more energy
now I've got a special bonus clip with
Tide Lopez on how to fix your bad mental
habits that I think will help you but
before that it's time for the three
point landing question it's time to go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what is your strong why number two how
can you better enjoy the moment and
number three what's the potential
alternate solutions fix your bad mental
habits what they don't teach you in
school is anything about habits yes they
make you memorize geography and what the
Capitol Montana is in the capital of
Romania but that doesn't translate into
anything of practical value besides
being good at geometry mate by geography
maybe which you could just google
nowadays it's outdated way of learning
what would help you is the proper mental
habits and one of those map mental
habits what did the masses do when they
see something new they're always
skeptical I saw that I put out a video
where I started sharing stuff in 2015
it's been viewed about three four
hundred million times this set of videos
are released
most people were skeptical Oh
Tod's what is this there's a big scam
but a handful of people got it one out
of a hundred and I don't like to say
this because all the advertising
compliance but there's a stack of people
who are become millionaires from those
techniques a stack of people become you
know gone from zero to six figures you
should train for that just like you know
in school remember they make you train
you got to climb up the rope and PE you
got to shoot a little basketball that
make you train with 9 times 9 is 81 and
6 times 6 is 36 all this training what
about the finance route and mental
training what about the habit training
to have the millionaire mindset nothing
if you want to know the seven Habits of
self-made millionaires check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
I should mention one thing about reading
it was at the library here at Columbia I
wish I spent probably more time than any
other
[Applause]